okay now I want to get into this issue
of the insults from the vice
presidential debate uh Tim Kaine first
brought up the accusation that his
opponents were relying on insults during
the campaign he said this has been an
insult riddled campaign I'm paraphrasing
here by Donald Trump and Mike Pence and
one of Mike Pence's sort of reflexive
almost tick like lines during the vice
presidential debate last night against
him Kane was accusing Hillary Clinton of
being insult driven while denying that
the Trump campaign was getting involved
in any insults and something he did
really brilliantly here and brilliantly
if we're evaluating this based on low
information lowest common denominator
voters is after Tim Kaine provided a
really extensive and accurate list of
the ways in which Donald Trump has
insulted people Mike Pence reacted as
though Tim Kaine mentioning those
insults was insulting or offensive uh
and this it it's just it's so stupid
right I mean it's so base and it's
shocking to me that pence would even
think to do it but in the same way that
Donald Trump clearly thinks a lot of his
supporters aren't that smart otherwise
he he wouldn't even try to get away with
half the stuff he tries to get away with
Mike Pence must also have a pretty low
opinion of his supporters or of the
average voter because if I say to you
someone called me an idiot I'm not
insulting anyone I am merely reporting
that I've been insulted and mike pence
was able to just turn it around and say
listen to all those insults coming out
of tim kaine's mouth let's take a listen
to this and see how you think of one
Donald Trump during this campaign is
called Mexicans rapists and criminals
he's called women slobs pigs dogs
disgusting I don't like saying that in
front of my wife and my mother he
attacked an Indiana born federal judge
and said he was unqualified to hear a
federal lawsuit because his parents were
Mexican he went after John McCain a poww
and said he wasn't a hero because he'd
been captured he said African Americans
are living in hell and he perpetrated
this outrageous and bigoted lie that
President
is that a US citizen if you want to have
a society where people are respected and
respect laws right you can't have
somebody at the top who demeans every
group that he talks about and I just
again I cannot believe that governor
pence will defend the insult driven
campaign that Donald Trump has run I
have to tell you just I was listening to
the avalanche of insults coming out of
Senator Caine that these days MacDonald
says he also hold on a sec my time
senator I didn't addresses your two
minutes thanks I forgive you yeah there
were no insults there from Tim Kaine
about Donald Trump these are quotes
about what Donald Trump said these are
all on record Trump did say the thing
about the Mexican rapists and criminals
although some he's sure are probably
good people Trump did talk about calling
women slobs pigs dogs and disgusting he
did attack an Indiana born federal judge
because of his up up / inherited I guess
uh Mexican heritage from his parents and
he did say of african americans are
living in hell every single one of those
statements Pat is something Donald Trump
said and might I do you think it was
effective for pence to say listen to all
those insults coming out of tim kaine's
mouth when they were just Trump quotes
was effective to people that may not
follow the news every day yeah but I
mean pence had an impossible job here
most the stuff that Trump has said
there's no way around it you can't
defend that yeah it's I in a way I don't
actually feel bad for pence because he
agreed to this nonsense uh but it it is
difficult to defend the indefensible
especially when the only when the best
path is to act like you've never heard
any of these quotes before you know that
you're in trouble and then pence
continuing to just act very shocked
about all the insults tough here's
another little clip for you ours is an
insult driven campaign I mean to be
honest with you Donald Trump had said
all the things that you said he said in
the way you said he said them he still
wouldn't have a fraction of the insult
that Hillary Clinton level when she said
that half of our supporters were a
basket of deplorable yeah so continuing
to deny the insult stuff throughout the
debate but you know what else was going
on during
the debate Donald Trump was on Twitter
insulting people while Mike Pence was
doing the dirty work and going on
national TV and embarrassing himself
with this gong show of Lies oh the
insults come from the Hillary Clinton
campaign here's one tweet that Donald
Trump sent out during the debate I agree
Kane looks like a fool and then another
tweet that Donald Trent Trump sent out
during the debate Kane looks like an
evil crook out of the Batman movies but
here's where things get really really
crazy talk about projection Donald Trump
tweeted during the debate that Hillary
Clinton's close ties to Vladimir Putin
deserves scrutiny what Eric Trump also
said it on CNN clearly this is a planned
coordinated effort I said last week
after the first presidential debate that
Donald Trump's performance in that first
debate has made Saturday Night Live
irrelevant because his performance was
indistinguishable from a parody of the
debate they seem to now be taking
campaign strategy from the parody of the
debate done by Saturday Night Live over
the weekend Trump's and pensa strategies
now are say that the opponent is doing
exactly what we are accused of and to
remind you when we talk about
psychological projection i'll put a
definition of this up on the screen for
you psychological projection is a theory
in psychology in which humans defend
themselves against their own unconscious
impulses or qualities both positive and
negative by denying their existence in
themselves while attributing them to
others for example a person who is
habitually rude may constantly accuse
other people of being rude it
incorporates blame shifting for example
when Fox News says everybody else is
biased we're fair and balanced really
they're the least fair of anybody on TV
when Donald Trump is the one suspected
of this allegiance or uh bromance or
whatever with Vladimir Putin then he
goes out and he says hey we've got a
look into the Hillary relationship with
without Vladimir Putin very very common
technique at first I was convinced Trump
is actually the more on here but the
more I observe this the
more convinced I am that Donald Trump
and Mike Pence just think that their
supporters are morons and whether you
say fifty percent of them are part of
the basket of deplorable zor not at this
point there are basically three ways
that I would understand a vote for
Donald Trump number one but you might
just be uninformed or incompetent right
you might does not really understand
what it is that's going on here you
might not understand their positions or
what it is that they they believe
etcetera number two you might just be
lacking mental capacity or faculties
right I mean you might have sort of
limited capacity to understand you be
maybe the dunning-kruger effect is a
factor and number three you might just
genuinely be a bad person I I don't
understand how you could be supporting
Donald Trump here and not fall into one
of those three categories and
yesterday's vice presidential debate
only made this abundantly clear Trump
tweeting insults and conspiracy theories
while Mike Pence is denying that Trump
has ever said these controversial things
it's really representative it's a
microcosm of what this campaign has been
so far let's take a break we have so
much more to discuss today and of course
i'm on twitter at d pakman I was
recently sent and I've been wearing a
really cool watch from movement watches
also known as mvmt and I absolutely love
this watch a lot of people have been
asking me about it movement watches is
interesting because they started
similarly to how the david pakman show
started which was it was too broke
college kids who wanted to wear stylish
watches but couldn't afford them so they
started their own watch company uh they
used crowd funding to build their
business in the same way that we at the
david pakman show have used crowd
funding to build the show the great
thing about movement watches is they
start at just $95 these are watches that
for this level of quality and design
you're talking about four to five
hundred dollars at department stores and
movement figured out that by selling
online you can cut out a lot of the
middle people and the retail markup and
offer the best possible prices so you
can actually get fifteen percent off
today with free shipping and free
returns by going to mvmt watches dot-com
/ pakman that's PA que ma n I love this
watch I love the clean design been
getting a ton of compliments and the
greatest part is I haven't been late to
a single meeting go to mvmt watches calm
/ Pakman PA que ma n